millie bobby brown is back on netflix
and this time she's the delightfully
smart and witty younger sister of the
world famous sherlock holmes in an
adventure that's set to kick off a brand
new franchise
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're diving into the ending of a
nola home as to examine
all the details and clues you might have
missed which set up the movie sequel
plus i'll reveal some easter eggs to the
original books obviously spoilers ahead
so take care
the ending of a nola home sees the
teenage detective not only solved the
case of the missing marquis by herself
and escaped the clutches of her
controlling brother mycroft but it also
teases a potential team-up for her and
sherlock in the final few scenes we get
to see how anola and her brother think
in a similar manner and how each seems
to playfully enjoy attempting to
outsmart the other
when anola finds a coded message in the
newspaper she initially assumes it's
from her missing mother
but quickly spots clues that reveal it
from sherlock instead
so she returns the trick by going to the
meeting place dressed as a boy
and hiding herself away from her
brothers however sherlock already
suspects that nola will know he planted
the message and senses that she'll turn
up anyway
and there's a clue that sherlock
probably spotted her disguise when he
walks through the colonnade and glances
to the right
then says i thought i saw something
sherlock continues walking but i can't
help thinking that he deliberately
decided to leave anola b and not let
onto his brother mycroft what he saw
after all he already spotted the clue
anola intentionally left for him so he
knew she was there somewhere
in contrast to mycroft sherlock seems to
have an understanding of who his sister
really is
after all they both share a passion for
detective work and i think he's deciding
to let anola be free
if that's what she wants still i do
expect we'll see the two of them
collaborate in some way in future
sequels
similar to how we already saw sherlock
mentoring anola earlier in the movie
look for what's there know what you want
to be there and at the end of the film
he also asks mycroft
if we do find her again i'd like it to
be my ward i'll take care of her in the
original anola holmes novels after
dodging and escaping her brothers for
the entire series in the final book
enola and sherlock finally reunite
and work together to solve a case and i
expect that in the movie franchise like
the books we'll see anola work in cases
by herself for a while and perhaps
crossing paths with sherlock from time
to time
she might even end up solving one of his
cases getting ahead of him again like
she did with the tewkesbury case
a full reunion of anola and sherlock too
early in the franchise wouldn't fit the
theme of anola being alone and making
her own way in the world but it could
come later once she's fully grown and
more established
although anola's mother eudoria is
absent for much of the movie her
influence is still felt throughout the
story for example she was responsible
for teaching enola reading
science sports and martial arts things
at the time traditionally only talk to
boys
and she also imbued a philosophy in
anola that she should decide her own
fate there are two pearls you can take
in ella yours
or the path others choose for you when
they reunite at the end of the film
eudoria explains that she left because
she wanted to change anola's future
and by that she means through her
involvement with the women's suffrage
movement
eudoria isn't able to stay with her
daughter she's clearly involved in
activities that make her a target for
the authorities however she thanks anola
for the irises and says if she ever
needs her again she'll be looking out
for them a reference to the secret coded
messages that anola left to her mother
in the newspapers
to find mother the first thing i need to
do is leave a cipher in every newspaper
she might read
are you blooming send iris please this
leaves things open for eudoria to return
or not
in a sequel and that might depend on how
much further the filmmakers want to
explore the beginnings of the women's
suffrage movement that are touched upon
in the first movie
the 1884 reform bill we see chukesbury
helped pass in the house of lords with
enola's help of course
expanded voting rights in the uk at the
time however the bill
failed to grant universal suffrage with
women excluded entirely and a further 40
percent of adult men excluded from any
voting rights
given the prominence of this storyline
in the first film andernola's budding
independence and activist mother
i expect a sequel to further investigate
the restrictions placed on women in the
late 19th century
in contrast to the books the movie
decides to develop a romantic connection
between anola and tewksbury right after
they fall off the train
by the end this romance has blossomed to
the point where we see anola place her
hand on his and then he kisses it
hopefully the sequels won't overdo the
romance after all anola turns down his
offer of living with him and his family
and insists on living independently as
she clearly wants to set herself
up as a professional detective still
fans of the couple hoping for
tewksbury's return and a sequel can look
to anola's words
you're not rid of me yet if i count
chews through my request of bazel ever
as for anola's eldest brother mycroft he
says he's glad to be free of his
responsibilities for her when sherlock
asked to be her guardian at the end
i'm curious though to see if mycroft
will continue to play an antagonistic
role towards our heroine in a sequel
he's clearly very reactionary in his
views towards women and society in
general
however by the end of the book series
mycroft ends up very impressed by nola's
skills and agrees to fund an education
for her so it'll be interesting to see
if
in time the movie franchise will redeem
mycroft in a similar way
i am not the villain here at the end of
the movie as anola concludes the story
she tells us that she's a detective
a decipherer and a finder of lost souls
the last point is a reference to the
books where anola decides she's going to
be what she calls a scientific
purgatorian
the word purgatorian is derived from the
latin term
poditus meaning lost and is a made-up
title in the novels where anola uses it
to refer to herself as a finder of loved
ones lost
there are numerous missing persons cases
in the books that the movie sequels may
adapt but one that's bound to prove
interesting
is the case of the bizarre bouquets in
which sherlock's associate dr watson
goes missing
i'll certainly be curious to see who's
cast as john watson
and how he might compare to martin
freeman's watson from the bbc
sherlock series in the books in order to
pursue her vocation of scientific
purgatorium anola has to masquerade as a
secretary because in the late 19th
century she says a scientist had to be a
man
so for the movie sequels it would be
interesting to see whether nola has to
disguise herself in the same
way or if she'll pretend to be a young
man as we've already seen her do in
order to pursue her detective work
and to learn a lot more about the
fascinating changes the anola homes
filmmakers made when adapting the
original book
tap here to watch my full video on that
or follow the link in the video
description
the link will be here as soon as the
video is ready so what did you think of
anola homes and what would you like to
see from her or sherlock in future
sequels
leave your thoughts in the comments
below if you enjoyed this don't forget
to leave a thumbs up and subscribe for
all my upcoming videos
tap left to watch my next nola homes
video or tap write for something else
you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers
you